this is actually a ended version of a
lecture I gave recently i gave the
plenary talk at the semicon west which
is the world's largest group gathering
of people who are sort of experts in the
semiconductor area but I wanted to take
it up a couple of levels and you know
one of the things that IBM has
tremendous emphasis on is the impact of
what we do on society and if you've been
at this as many years or many decades as
I have you know you do have a concern
because we can make huge differences in
people's lives unimaginable if you just
pay attention it's very easy to ignore
the hard stuff right the grand
challenges but if you set a challenge
for yourself and you said it to be
something that will actually change the
way the world works and then you pull it
off and grand challenges don't always
work that's why they call them grand
challenges you know Albert Einstein
disliked intensely the whole concept of
doing quantum mechanics you know God
doesn't play craps with the universe i
believe is one of the more famous quotes
but the fact is he pursued a grand
unifying field theory through the
remainder of his life attempting to
resolve something that he felt would be
you know seminal and it didn't work of
course his contributions are so
extraordinary that will nobody his name
will never be lost to history even
though one of the Grand Challenges he
undertook he was not successful in
closing out that's just how that is but
it is very important when you work in
any field I don't care what field you
ultimately go into that you just keep in
the back of your mind there are places
where innovation you know the big stuff
you're going to do does matter will have
a profound impact and just keep your
eyes open to that because you'd be
amazed what you can miss there are a
couple of rather large challenges out
there and I wanted to just set the stage
because all of these things ultimately
are basically handled believe it or not
as challenges through information
technology in a very large part now in
fact I had a very interesting meeting
where before this in fact somebody was
telling me gee I'm going to work on
water management as part of my studies
in computer science and I think that's
very cool because in fact there's a
problem here
right now if you ask people will you
have a major crisis in water supply in
36 states were you have folks who own
this issue they say yeah in the next two
years I will at least once have a major
crisis in water supply okay that's way
better than half the u.s. if you look at
China China already suffers as you well
know from dramatic problems in water
supply and that's not just shortage but
it's also quality and they're working
very very hard on what's a critical
societal issue India is projected
basically to have the world's first just
there ain't enough water for the
population by 2025 and oh by the way as
you know the snowcaps and in the
Himalayas and elsewhere in that area
that supply that region are diminishing
to the point that you will come to a
crisis state you need to address these
things traffic now this is you know
prototypically what you find in places
like Los Angeles I don't think i have to
tell you where that was the problem is
right now if you do quantitative
measurements here people just looking
for a parking spot in this one segment
they took a small area of LA and they
said how bad is it people looking for a
parking spot basically drove around the
world the equivalent of 38 times
searching for a place to put their car
they burned about 47,000 gallons of fuel
in the process and put about seven
hundred or so tons of carbon diox-- and
the atmosphere that's not going anywhere
is that's just looking for somewhere to
put their vehicle congested roads in the
u.s. right now burn up about 78 billion
dollars according to the best estimates
in terms of just wasted time lost hours
millions and millions of gallons of fuel
Burt in the US distributing food another
challenge and these things again if you
think about it if I tea and you actually
have solved the Traveling you know
you've heard anybody here heard of the
Traveling Salesman problem right the
most of right of course the most
efficient way to get to a tizzy well you
know the traveling carrot problem right
a sixteen hundred mile carrot you can
probably do better just guessing here
the you know truck Rose that goes 600
miles the twelve hundred mile potato I
mean this is amazing and despite all of
the
roles we have you throw out about 48
billion dollars of food a year because
it spoils it just doesn't get to where
it's going and by the way you should
have probably thrown out another 48
billion dollars but instead you
compensate by eating at mingo into the
hospital it's not a good deal there's a
lot of work to be done health care is
another mess they estimate that about
2.2 million dispensing errors are made
because people handwrite their
prescriptions and by the way if you
haven't heard their illegible I think
you know that the health care system is
estimated to lose 100 billion dollars
years to fraud and that is a very
lowball estimate that is actually
probably very very conservative IT can
track all these things and the premises
it's either we lack the information we
need to address these kinds of
challenges or we can't utilize it
effectively because there is a deluge of
it coming at us and as you know too much
information if you're fighting a case in
law you know what the first thing you do
to the other side to make their life
misery you don't hide anything from them
hell you give them everything including
the last week's toilet paper I mean you
just hear it is bunk and you literally
deliver four trucks of papers and
somewheres in there is the one they're
looking for and somewhere is in about
three hundred years they will locate
this so what they do is they put 300
lawyers on it for one year and that
burns up so much money that the person
you're fighting with Rose our hands up
mirror and says I quit it's ridiculous
but that is again it's something that
happens finding that nugget of data is
really the most amazing challenge we
face and it is the responsibility of the
folks who create the technology to
enable us to step up and address these
kinds of problems technologists whether
you're in the hardware or the software
side are the people who will solve these
societal issues they're not going to
solve themselves this isn't something in
a wish away and no amount of work with a
shovel or no amount of work with a
pencil is going to get this done we are
way past that now the concept of a
smarter planet and how you know the
issues we've been chasing these are
basically what an industry our industry
in fact the one certainly I've worked
most of my life in which is in the
technology side of this can enable and
what we decided to do is because of the
unbelievable
number of things you can chase I'm just
and I'll give you a few examples later
we really focused heavily on the issue
of just you know how we would work
within smarter cities because they make
a great microcosm smarter cities are a
great place to focus because about fifty
percent of the world's population is
going to live there in a matter of years
and about twenty five percent of the
entire domestic product of the planet
comes from the top hundred cities today
twenty-five percent of the world's gdp
comes out of just a handful of states so
again this is a it was a place we
decided to start now in the industry we
work in the technology industry we
actually can make things both
economically and technically feasible
this is the first aha what percentage of
the Wi-Fi revolution right 802 11 God
you know what 802 11 is right a be okay
what percentage with the Wi-Fi market do
you think IBM was for the first let's
say ten years that it started up
approximately less than ten percent less
than thirty percent but you guys are
optimist but less than fifty percent all
right let's go the other extreme one
hundred percent okay no votes one
hundred percent okay did anybody even
have a clue we were involved not a
chance you could make 802 11 Wi-Fi and
long before we got there and they sold
couple hundred a year why it costs
thousand two thousand bucks apiece they
were built on gallium arsenide all kinds
of exotic technologies in the case of
the silicon germanium program I let our
goal wasn't to build something that
could outperform gallium arsenide we did
but that was not the goal the goal was
to build something a factor of a
thousand less expensive why because if
you're selling the chips that are
required to make Wi-Fi for a thousand
bucks it's never going to happen the
damn computer quest emanated just isn't
going to happen if you can sell the
chips or ten dollars ah then you sell a
hundred million Wi-Fi cards and we're in
all of them even today anybody here ever
see one of these how do you spell
blackberry guess what radio front ends
ours we economically enable them don't
fall in love with technology alone
important keep in mind that if the gold
plating is thick enough it'll never sell
and never become impactful in society
this is what I mean about smarter planet
you got to be smarter right if you have
essentially something that's going to
cost thousands of times more than
anybody's willing to pay it's probably
not smart to pursue it there are lots of
things we work on in this business this
is the laundry list of those things but
they've got to fit within a financial
envelope that they actually get into
society because nobody can afford in a
place where you're having trouble living
on two dollars a week average you
know average earnings per capita they're
not going to be able to afford a sensor
that helps prevent them from becoming
ill from spoiled food if the sensor
costs the hundred dollars the sensor
costs one cent and you could lay this
chemical sensor strip on top of the meat
that you have in your kitchen and if it
turns purple throw it away that's great
people will do that so again you just
got to keep in mind me it's got to work
in many many ways not just physically
now the track record in this industry
and here's the good news is amazing the
people love numbers you know billion
million trillion this is great what all
it says is for the same amount of money
you now can buy about a billion times as
many computations as you stay but be
able to buy in the year nineteen hundred
but I don't really think I don't like
this particular version of you know how
far we've come and why I have such faith
that we will solve these problems I got
a better example in my view anyway which
is I'm about 62 if in 1956 I was
standing in front of my house and I'm
that height and I simply grew in height
at the same rate that computer systems
grew in their ability to crank way how
told would I be today and the answer is
if I were to look down at present day I
would see the moon wrap around the earth
and smack me in the ankles real numbers
by the way that's really by the way
really simple math petabyte kilobyte to
get petaflop Killa flop right 10 to 15
10 to the right ten 10 to the 12th
differential 10 to the call five never
mind you can do the math on that and
somebody sitting over there doing no
the thumbs are working medley in any
case you know here's a very interesting
thing about why technology is such a
challenge why the world today we live in
is so different and it really is
different those of you working in
software of those of you working in
systems those of you working smart grid
all of those elements there's a real
focus on that because what happens to us
in technology is this we have twice
taken technologies and scale them to
such a small dimension that the power
went insane the laws of scaling say that
when you make things smaller classical
scaling if you're going to put a million
times as many things on the chip which
is Moore's Law after 50 years right you
put twice as much on ship every year
after 50 years you've now got a million
times as much on the chip so if you had
a one square centimeter chip you're not
having a million times as many things on
your same one square centimeter if you
haven't done anything about the power
that would mean that if it was a 10 watt
chip here it's now a 10 million watch up
here which in a laptop provides you with
a brief but extraordinarily exciting
experience when you turn them on that's
a problem and what happened is the way
we got to that problem is there was a
recipe that said you make things smaller
if you follow this recipe if you have
twice as many things on the ship each
burns half as much twice in history once
for bipolar and once we see most people
violated those scaling rules with these
huge bumps of power and in fact that
chip up there at the very top was an
Intel chip called Prescott which got so
out of control power wise they had to
terminate the entire program and start
over again with a different design point
my point is we have been counting on
success where this will go on forever to
the right and you would announce new
things with constant power and because
the laws of physics say you can't
continue to make things smaller forever
basically that has now failed well if
you're not getting this massive
performance that you're used to getting
every new generation you'll still get
density you can make things more dense
but they don't perform a lot better you
better find other means to do it and
people have they've gone from just
pushing transistors to pushing
multi-core adding things like embedded
dram you have local storage of data
right on the chip why is that because
you waste ridiculous
amounts of power getting data on and off
the chips you want to cash on the check
why ed Ram versus what's called SRAM
which is usually how they store data on
a chip because it's four hundred percent
more dense all of these architectural
tricks they're not believed as technical
that architectural are now coming into
play and there's a ton of software
behind them to leverage them now Giga
Hertz is gone there was this foot race
we were trained Pavlovian style i
actually know people crazy enough to
have slept out in front of you know
stores waiting for the first 100
megahertz processor you know this is
like a cheap throat I mean I know you
know we sit here now going you gotta be
kidding right there are people okay I
know they need to get a life I got that
part but aside from them being
incorrigible nerds the fact of the
matter is that was a big deal because
we'd been taught forever Pavlovian style
things have to go faster and that's how
we get more speed out of a machine the
joke is clock frequency went down if you
look at the current chipsets from Intel
there are a lot slower than they used to
be in terms of the clock frequency
they're using other tricks and
innovation is taken many forms the other
thing is like I said just making things
smaller doesn't work anymore the reason
is really simple if you make things
small enough you get down to atomic
dimensions and if you're planning on
using nuclear fission to make the atom
smaller let me know so I can get far
away so the thing that's happened is
people have introduced new materials not
just a few before the 1990s the base
materials used in silicon technology are
highlighted here this is for left-handed
people that's right number one the you
know it's basically just aluminum for
your metallurgy silicon is your
semiconductor phosphorous and born are
respectively or N and P dopants and then
oxygen is for making your insulator this
piece of cake and by the way in the
nineties you're talking about the system
being for the technology was like 40
years old at this point and that's all
people used but it got a little harder
so through 2005 people had to get a
little more clever so then they added
fluorine and chlorine and germanium and
copper and titanium and silicides and
all of a sudden you were adding all
these new materials you know why because
you made the thing smaller and it no
longer was faster better cheaper it
actually got really hot didn't go any
faster and
threaten the set fire to the machine so
you had to invent all kinds of tricks
now to get more performance out of the
technology other than shrinking it and
then came post 2005 now I have the
dubious honor of actually having
announced in 2003 that you couldn't make
things smaller anymore without doing all
this because you'd set fire to the user
the reason that was dubious in 2004
somebody showed up and actually put my
face up on a slide like this was a big
red circle and a bar across it and said
you know ban Bernie because he said the
end of Moore's Law is coming didn't
quite say that I said that the end of
scaling would come it did so after 2005
a funny thing happened you had to do a
few other things to get performance
that's actually what's currently in use
in technology today by the way the
periodic table and by the way if people
could figure out how to use radial you
know plutonium without killing anyone
they'd probably go for it the problem is
that this has gotten incredibly
difficult now there are salts who still
cling to this notion that you know we're
going to do more of more which is make
things smaller faster better cheaper and
that's a really nice theory but the
reality is it's very hard to do so
you're getting into now some really
exotic transistors the reason these are
exotic cuz these guys are standing up
vertically from the surface for the last
50 years transistors lay flat on the
surface the trouble is that if it lays
flat on the surface you can't do enough
to the surface to get adequate
performance once you get down below
about 22 nanometers so what's happening
is people are actually looking at taking
the transistor literally standing a
little thin thin of silicon off the
surface so they can wrap a electrically
controlled and gate around it and pinch
off the electrical current through it to
cut down on leakage I mean these things
are unimaginably complicated to build
also there are other devices we're
looking at that are literally different
than a standard transistor this is a
silicon nanowire these little wires here
are incredibly tiny and only about five
nanometers or 50 angstroms are about a
hundred atoms across and there you
actually put a gate around the device
it's like a tube so you have a silicon
conducting to lock side around that you
wrap a piece of metal around that and
you can turn the tube on and off I mean
these again are very exotic devices they
do work but you struggle to get them to
work
this is very difficult but you know what
you haven't got a lot of choice there's
some really fancy stuff where these are
carbon nanotubes I think some of you
probably heard of those this is a
material actually called
buckminsterfullerene and when you know
why his Buckminster Fuller really liked
this particular shape that the carbon
exists in and in fact had built a whole
series of geodesic domes and other
things using that structure so when it
came up somebody nailed that back by the
way has been around here's a useless
fact do you know when this stuff was
actually produced first that's 1,800
yeah about 1800 they didn't know what
the heck it was at the time they thought
it was like talcum powder they in the
old theaters they used to use our clamps
we took two pieces of carbon you put
them close together ran a high current
between them and that our cable off a
tremendous amount light that's how they
illuminated the stages at the very early
times that people were using electricity
rather than just using natural gas or
some other flame the thing is when you
do that arc the fuzz that you find at
the bottom of that arc lamp it's by the
way buckminsterfullerene so they didn't
realize they could have almost won a
Nobel Prize if they know what the heck
it wasn't there's a lot of stories like
that you'd be surprised in any case the
problem you get into is at the end of
the day there are quantum mechanical
limits the silicon and you have to find
other ways around this this is one of
the reasons why this field is getting
tough and this is one of the reasons why
you guys have a tremendous opportunity
to add value because I will tell you
that carbon nanotube transistors and
graphene transistors made out of a
single plane of rat fight these were all
really nice ideas which somewheres in
the next two centuries will come to
fruition right now it remains pretty
much as it has been which is the time it
will be between when you're talking and
when they'll be ready is the time
constant of 20 years eventually it will
stop being a constant it will shrink to
zero I hope but for the moment there's a
huge amount of work here and it's
valuable work and it has to be done
because you have to solve these problems
but right now we don't have any of these
alternatives to Silicon available and as
their for progress slows we need people
to be working in other fields another
interesting thing even if you can
produce these huge amounts of data on a
chip
shipping the data is another physical
problem believe it or not you can't get
electrical signals on and off a modern
ship fast enough there what they call IO
bound so people are working on
incredibly clever things where they
actually stack chips in three dimensions
and the actual off-chip communications
are based on photonics this is sort of
long lines of cheating mother nature you
know you're using wavelengths of light
that are ten times larger than some of
the bends you want the light to make
that gets very exciting to direct it
around those corners but people have
done it and there are a lot of very
interesting ways of doing it with
evanescent waves and other things of
that nature again another point is when
you get into doing these sort of very
sophisticated tricks you actually can
push the field forward but interestingly
this is not about just semiconductor
technology now this is an incredibly
complicated data set where you have
multiple processors an entire plane of
memory that's close coupled you have
photonics above it controlling this
thing in a sensible fashion so you can
actually leverage what maybe five cores
per chip or six so you know six eight
cores per chip times perhaps 50 chips in
a block accessing memory and even
sharing that memory coherently among
multiple chips good luck this isn't a
hugely complex thing and it is coming
quickly we are reaching the point in the
roadmap of Technology where the demands
on the hardware and software side will
lead to what I call co.design
exclusively it already is being done
people co-designed hardware and software
to get the rest result but this will
become not just a something that's a
nice to have it will be something that
you will must have and what I think
you're going to start to see his
department's that work in this field are
actually going to coalesce because it is
through the kind of co design that you
will get the benefit at the system level
which is all anybody cares about there's
a lot of work going on in optics another
field that really in silicon had very
very little place until quite recently
now people are integrating on-chip
optics for this very reason URI o bound
you simply can't get data on and off the
chip fast enough and even if you could
it cost you too much power to do it if
you try to ship data any kind of
distance the RC time constants and the
power that's burned in doing so become
unbearable right now some of the
your chips we have roughly speaking half
the power the chip this goes into
getting data on and off fifty percent is
doing nothing more than shipping data
you're not actually computing anything
ah then there's the cost thing remember
my warning at the beginning you know
beware what you hope for it may be
expensive all this innovation that I've
been describing it doesn't come cheap
and again it teaches you you now have to
innovate another way is one of which is
how you work together and the reason is
this that is an euv system this is
basically the next generation a
lithographic tool to shoot things that
are down at the dimension of let's say
10 angstroms to 20 angstroms somewheres
in that range you're going to get 10 to
20 min animators rather you're going to
get basically to the point you're using
these kinds of little tools that tool
give or take cost about 167 million
dollars you know give or take a few
million roundoff error the thing about
it is it looks a bit like imagining the
largest electromagnet you've ever seen
imagine powering it up and walking
through an automobile junkyard that's
pretty much what this thing looks like
but nonetheless it costs 167 million
bucks if you're going to do this kind of
work you also have to ask can you
sustain that cost now the reason I'm
telling you this again has to do with
the fact that you have to sort of
rethink where you're looking for value
and adding value in this business it
turns out if you look at the rate of
growth of total semiconductor of
investment in black and then the rate of
growth of the actual revenues in red you
will notice those two curves actually
look like they're going to cross at some
point that's a really bad thing what
does that translate to when I started in
this business there were 300 leading
edge fabs in silicon working in the
basics today there are two to the place
you know anybody here know where the
integrated circuit was invented who
invented the IC here's that kill me Jack
Kobe invented it they invented a Texas
Instruments big barns new key
right I know right there's a religious
debate which I'll stay at it but you are
correct it ti basically is where they
have the quote kilby Center which no
longer does any work in this field even
texas instruments which is sort of the
last of the holdouts gave up about three
four years ago it said I'm out of here
it is remarkable and it's because of the
cost of staying in this it is
unimaginably large investments just to
build a modern fab today is about a five
billion dollar single expense one-fifth
so you know the problem is and I don't
want to overstate this just to do one
generation of technology right now is
something on the order of about 2.3
billion dollars for the current
generation that's just the rd that
doesn't actually get you a wafer we're
putting in another way your first chip
cost two point three billion dollars
beyond that the chips get a lot cheaper
per but that initial ones a killer so
you know you have to actually figure out
how you innovate and innovation can
actually be cultural and strange as it
may seem you folks will exist in a
different culture than I did the culture
I existed in there were a bunch of
Yahoo's there's well I think was a Negro
who was it who said written I wasn't
this guy from national real men half
fabs there was a book published and i'll
have to remember I it was attributing it
to Andy Grove of Intel but it wasn't it
was a guy who actually ran national
semiconductor and it was an era of
yahoo's everybody could afford a fair
house after all so that's what you did
the idea of working with your neighbor
that was out of the question I mean
collaboration what are you kidding me
the whole point was to strangle them not
to work with them it's a little
different now in fact the world is
turned completely upside down right now
Silicon Valley is relocated to New York
which is strange but hard realities when
Texas Instrument exited even SEMATECH
which is the u.s. consorcio working on
advanced tech moved back up into albany
new york where in fact we built a
multi-billion dollar leading edge
research center not just development but
really are working all the way down to
about the 10 nanometer level that tool
shown there was in fact that SUNY Albany
which has become a mess
international site and all the countries
shown all the companies shown there from
all over the world actually have their
main research center in albany now tokyo
electron limited which is located all
over japan as the second largest
supplier of tools in the world has
actually shut down their japan-based
research centers and moved into in fact
albany samsung actually has their base
research center will be shipping their
first actual technology at 32 nanometer
based upon all the work done jointly in
albany and in fact what has happened is
there's a whole series of large fab
where this thing is actually a full flow
fab it's not like I make in Europe where
it's it's what they call a where you do
unit process you know where you do an
oxide or it's an actual fan you actually
can build full chips and this investment
of multiple billions of dollars has had
a profound impact because the way it
began is all these companies looked at
this and said you know if we work
individually we're going to get killed
so why don't we form an alliance and the
Alliance which was formed is about twice
rough we're roughly twice the size of
Intel a little larger than that actually
in terms of total investment it's the
largest single group of semiconductor
folks we don't run around at Albany with
a little bad saying and I'm from Samsung
I'm probe stmicroelectronics that's
nonsense it's a single team and we do
what they call pre-competitive work
because that pre-competitive
collaborative innovation and it is
really radical collaboration these are
people who will later kill each other in
the market we compete but the when
you're pushing the laws of physics you
really do need to have this critical
mass of incredibly bright people and you
learn to put aside who you are and
actually work as a team and it's had a
profound impact because when that
happened all the other folks who supply
this industry said wow you know they
become adults they actually collaborate
openly so what do they do they showed up
because it's an ecosystem right you've
got all it's it's the largest single
group of people working in the field in
the world so I might as well show up
because like if I get approved in the
process that they're going to develop I
own piece of it then beyond that you get
a lot of people in fact who came in from
the tooling and materials area so it's
not just the manufacturing and other
work associated with manufacturing that
came in all the tools guy
showed up as well as a whole lot of the
people who bring intellectual property
in form of circuit design so this is
actually what is now in Albany so what
started out eight nine years ago is this
little tiny you know cut shop of little
let's grow a film has become this
massive undertaking it just grew
exponentially and it's here in the US
it's something that we basically do
better than most folks and you know
we've been very very lucky and in fact
they now teach this at Harvard Business
School is one of the entry level courses
it's called radical collaboration these
are people who should more naturally
beat the hell out of each other who said
you know what you're pushing the
absolute limits of science and
technology here and why don't we just at
least put aside our differences in
pre-competitive work and get on with it
and there are people who could never get
over themselves and participate in such
a thing and i believe it's their loss
because what i found is as smart as you
may believe you are there are other
people out there who are smarter and
you're better off working with them then
against them it's really easy you know
one of the most interesting experiences
in my career at IBM is IBM could be a
rather humbling experience because never
underestimate two people you have in a
company of 400,000 folks that's been
around for a hundred years and I was
sitting in a bar in kearsley England I'm
sorry we sit in pubs we don't you know
where IBM he's gonna go to bars so I'm
sitting in a pub in Herzlich England
we're about to go the next day myself
and for colleagues and discuss what it's
like to have a technical career in the
company and my four colleagues are
sitting there were about three quarters
away through this and I look around and
I said guys you know no offense but I
don't really fit in with this bunch I
got to get out of here and they looked
at me like I had had a little too much
to drink and I pointed out that fellas I
am the only person at this table who
does not have a Nobel Prize
yeah that's little there's a level set
haha that's a Garrard in a guy me ridin
up the right high-temperature
superconductivity scanning tunneling
microscope I mean and by the way these
are the most normal I mean they're great
scientist but they're actually pretty
normal human beings they'll gird is a
little but gird when he won the Nobel
Prize he marches out of the building
there are literally hundreds of
reporters sound trucks satellites right
and they're standing there they have
these huge bouquets of flowers which is
the tradition in Europe that they hand
the winner he walks out he's working
these shorts and a t-shirt he once out
the door says I haven't got time for you
guys I gotta go play a soccer match
because you know he can't let IBS so he
goes and he actually plays the game so
the first picture we have of him after
he won the Nobel prizes he's standing
there collecting these flowers with
blood running from his lips and from his
shins and it's great great shot so but
that's you know it's it's the accurate
portrayal of a guy now you know we have
all of these things that I t can do but
we sometimes underestimate how hard it
is to do them or how much the demand is
this is also kind of level set they're
about two million people on the web this
year and it's estimated to grow very
very rapidly to 4 billion within the
next three or four years so you know gee
whiz 4 billion people right there'll be
about 1.3 billion RFID tags as about six
years ago nowadays there however are 33
billion hmmm that's growing rapidly
however where it gets really interesting
is people get all excited about data
that this generates right we'll have to
store 10 times as much in a five-year
period from 2006 to this year 10 times
here's what they miss the Internet of
Things the demands on what you have to
build what you have to handle in the
software and hardware you create go up
two thousand fold from the Internet of
Things say we're we're sitting here
thinking you know Wow four billion
people how about one trillion things are
connected to the Internet that's pretty
much now and they all spew data those
things exist all around you you have
thermal sensors and here all of you
working on smart grid you understand
that your dishwasher will ultimately
say hey is there enough power of me to
turn on now or should I wait 30 minutes
then there's the photovoltaic supply
outside that is querying another
organization that maintains the weather
forecast to see if it's going to be
sunny in two hours because if it's going
to be sunny in two hours they're going
to send something out saying hey wash
your clothes two hours from now all of
that requires data vast amounts of it
and it flies back and forth when you're
sitting there going hmm you know how how
do I keep up with this so the demands on
what we have to build in this industry
here's the quandary I just finished
telling you this stuff ain't getting
better quickly in fact it's not getting
better at all the rate of progress in
semiconductors we are struggling we
aren't struggling and then you compound
that with the demands that are going
through the roof so good luck guys i
retire have a nice day not going to
happen so the way you do this is you
really move way up the stack we call it
a holistic design the good news is you
can get multiplicative benefit if you
work the whole sack if you go from atoms
and molecules all the way out to the
system architecture around the globe you
wouldn't believe the benefit you can get
versus being I make chips and I love it
there there was a history as you know
where I make a chip you know actually
you have to put a little sign on your
computer this as you see I made the chip
will be yeah that's about one-tenth of
one percent of the problem right the
chip doesn't really run without any
software and oh by the way if the
software is no use if you haven't
connected this to something else and oh
by the way there are no sensors out
there well then this can't do anything
and oh yeah then you need activate
actuators I mean this is just a little
piece of the puzzle but if you work
holistically up and down you can do some
pretty amazing stuff now there are some
innovations we've made working A to Z
that are kind of cute this is one of
them it's called streams processing so
much data as I said earlier is being
generated in flowing in what do you do
with it well one of the things you want
to do with it is you want to reduce that
until you get to the point where there's
a human that's feeding this being fed a
consumable set of data this is to some
extent what Watson buzz Watson is a
snapshot right well Watson says that you
ask it a question and it takes this huge
amount of potential input but gets it
down to the pool
that presents you with an answer or at
least something it thinks as an answer
with some odds on it this is very
effective if you think about what
happens for instance in let's pick a
random example orange juice very
sophisticated example right orange juice
you're a company Tropicana you buy
oranges and make orange juice why is
this important because you want to
monitor the New York Stock Exchange all
the filings with the various commissions
video news weather data why because the
hurricane that was going to make
landfall in Mexico suddenly turns north
and heads for the orange groves you want
to be the first company this has a
system that says hey wait a minute
they're back they're about to run down
our orange supply with a hurricane I
strongly suggest we buy every orange you
can get our hands on in Texas in other
places right now because it's going to
get really expensive in about three
minutes when somebody else figures out
the weather forecast just change the
name condemn any oranges I mean not
rocket science you think but you got to
do it in a micro second good luck with
that this isn't data mining this isn't
where you collect the data and go back
and say hey I've got no oranges this is
not a useful finding that's kind of like
hey I'm going to starve to death grade
you want to be a little more proactive
that means you have to go back and do
this on the fly this is a dynamic
process and that's very very powerful so
that again is another way using a whole
host of tricks this isn't this is
decision engines its software hardware
it's I oh it's doing things on the fly
instead of after the fact again this is
another level you can take this problem
to in order to attack these grand issues
this is another one I like so there's a
hospital in Toronto it's called sick
kids please I didn't choose the name
every time I say that people look at me
like you know that is the name of the
hospital sick kids hospital it has a
terrific reputation particularly for
dealing with preemies the problem with a
preemie is an interesting one premature
infants of course when born have very
underdeveloped everything including
immune systems well that's catastrophic
because hospital is unfortunately a
notorious for having
infections that transmit it in the
hospital the code nosocomial infections
any infection you acquire in your
hospital stay the trouble with the
preemie is they don't behave like an
adult buzz when you get sick when an
adult becomes ill and you're going to
get a cold what happens you start
blowing your nose you sneeze that's your
signal something is coming on your body
is reacting to an infection and it's
it's sort of your early warning system
as your body spools up and fights it in
a preemie they don't have an early
warning system so what happens is the
child becomes more and more infected
more and more septic and then suddenly
and very suddenly dies the child crashes
and dies because there's no early
warning it's not like they develop a
fever how they going to develop a
favorite they haven't got a significant
immune system to have that reaction
they're not going to develop congestion
their immune system hasn't spooled up
they just die they become septic they go
into septic shock and there's no
recovery you need to discover this
problem as early as humanly possible
that there's an infection pending so
what they do a child throws off 100 200
300 data points per second as to
respiratory rate heart rate any kind of
variations in any of the above
temperature body weight
electroencephalograph activities a huge
and a blood gas I mean you name it it's
all monitored what if you took all that
data every second for months until the
child either successfully hopefully left
the hospital or god forbid night and
what if you went back and then you
compared the child's pet by you look at
all that data and say where was there a
signal something's wrong because no
alarm went off the heart rate was right
temperature was right blood press right
until the child died it turns out if you
go back and look at this again the power
of what I showed earlier data mining and
technology and sensors and all that
taken together the system solution now
is what they found was the child's heart
beat actually should be quite variable
young preemies their heart rate varies
old wanders all over the place the
bizarre part is as they become infected
for whatever reason the actual variance
in the heart rate goes away
a-and the heartbeat becomes actually
much more regular and pretty much in the
center of the sweet spot of where it
should be which means no alarms are ever
going to go off except that
stabilization of the heartbeat is what
signals that impending the impending
fatal infection we can now using this
technique when I say we I mean the
hospital can pick this up 24 to 48 hours
ahead of the best ICU nurse and treat 24
hours to 48 hours early which is the
difference between children living and
dying so what we do doesn't operate in a
vacuum it does not operate in a vacuum i
gave this talk in israel last year after
the i gave that example in israel after
their new year and one of the CEOs that
we had invited came up and you know
hugged me and turned said look you know
my child died three weeks ago of those
commonly infection you know this is good
stuff thank you and he walked out you
sit there and you scratch your head and
you there's no good reaction to that
other than that you know what you do
matters remember what I said at the
beginning keep your eyes open this isn't
what people set out to do when they
invented screams processing I promise
you it is what happened and it is what's
in use today so pay attention it's it's
never necessarily a straight line from A
to Z right there there are times we this
is not what they had in mind but this is
what came out of it and it actually
makes a huge difference there are many
ways you can use this stuff well another
example is if you have a city and you
know where everybody in the city is in
their car interesting not whose car it
is because there's a car here there are
this many cars going by the spot they're
going in a certain speed if you take the
history of the city just like following
a child you can predict 20 minutes from
now believe it or not what things will
look like you can predict the number of
cards that will be at that spot in the
speed of those cars because you have a
lot of historical data you can actually
predict the future you build a model
these are interesting curves it looks
like there's one this set of curves is a
ten minute ahead forecast in blue of the
automobile speed and in black is what
actually happens so in other words we
draw the black line after the blue line
the blue is our prediction growing ten
minutes ahead of the event and the black
is what actually occurs you will notice
they just sit on top of each other it is
astounding how accurately you can
predict this why does this matter
I'm not going to come back and tell you
by the way 10 minutes from now you're
going to be stuck in a traffic jam that
doesn't exist that's not the goal the
goal is the jam never happens why
because if i look at the speed of cars
which is 10 minutes ahead here and I see
the blue line falls off a cliff the
first thing I do is I start to reduce
the number of vehicles I allow to get to
that spot in the city by adding just two
or three seconds delay to the lights
that move people towards that spot
because it's over use in a spot that
causes congestion and all you have to do
many times is reduce the number of
vehicles by a few percent and the jam
never happens Proactive okay this is a
foundationally new way of thinking of
the use of IT we are changing the future
we're not just predicting it we are
changing it and that's a pretty
remarkable thing now this is pretty much
it you know as a company and as a group
of people working in this field
particularly the technologists we work
in all of these areas that impact all of
those quote green things that I showed
earlier all of those grand challenges
every one of these has a piece of it so
this was my lecture as I said
challenging the entire technology
industry to focus on doing you know
better things with what they produce and
so you know I wrapped it up here I said
look innovation is now the only thing
driving our industry the straight line
stuff doesn't work anymore consolidation
and globalization of society of our
industry and everything else they're
just going to continue and become the
norm systems will be the differentiators
period this is what I've been showing
all the long it is the system solutions
that really change the world it is not
wow I got a g-wiz faster transistor
didn't change the world those days are
becoming scarce er it's not to say
somebody won't invent the new transistor
or gee whiz device that makes a big
impact but it is to say that's not going
to be the big thing and as an industry
and when I talk about an industry I mean
in the broader sense as an IT industry
we have a profound ability to change
society and we have demonstrated at the
time and time and time again you haven't
even seen the
beginning of it if people can ever get
over the concept that if you run a pig
backwards through a grunt you know
through a grinder yes you get sausage
but if you take the sausage running
backwards through the grinder you do not
get a pig okay if people could ever get
past that which is another way of saying
you can anonymize data and it really is
anonymous if they can ever get over that
we could actually share medical records
and actually do this kind of data mining
and work and learn a lot more about
health care okay that by the way I stole
shamelessly from his friend of mine a
Jeff Jonas who is sort of the Wildman of
IBM we bought this guy's little number
we bought his company everybody see the
movie 21 all right this is about a bunch
of guys who went down and ripped off the
casinos using card counting yeah yeah
guess who took them down yeah yeah Jeff
was one of the best guys I've ever seen
with stuff like that but one of the
things he also contributed was the part
about running the pig but running the
sausage backward through the grinder and
not getting a pig one of the things that
gets in our way is there are still
issues in society we need to overcome
about letting us use these techniques
and use them in private for the benefit
of society but the fact of the matter is
there you haven't seen anything yet
because some of the things we'd like to
do have been blocked and will eventually
open up with I believe profound
consequences for society and us in
general so I'm going to stop there thank
you and you know a few minutes of
questions if you want
yeah I've got two questions sure once
facetious I think I think that is the
challenge proving people you actually
have a grinder the less facetious
question is one of the things that is
not on your smarter find out who
slightly smarter education since you're
sitting on university oh yeah that's
that's I actually have a 40 paid
presentation on that which is why I
didn't put it there because once it was
like I know and once I get going on that
we're dead um yeah smarter education
probably as an example um about a simple
example starting at the base kids in New
York on average carrier of book bags
that weigh 45 pounds in the city to my
understanding spends approximately 180
million dollars a year to grind up a
tree soak it in toxic chemicals dispose
of those chemicals print it print you
know flattened to paper print on it and
then ship it to someplace 180 million
bucks here to do this right so we
destroy a wonderful natural resources
some kid can have spinal problems
excellent perhaps we wanted you know
electronic delivery of material we're
not talking rocket science reporting
Kendall that's about as far from rocket
science is you're going to get but
believe it or not it's that simple that
crude at this stage in terms of moving
to smarter education it's amazing and I
wish I could set I would love to say
something profound about our cross
training and cry forget that we're
carrying around 45 pounds of books as a
nine-year-old child you know we
sometimes lose sight of the easy stuff
because it's cheaper and simpler so
that's a great question but there's a
much more efficient yeah there's much
more much much more to it beyond that I
I'm not minimizing it at all quite the
opposite is sort of a favourite topic
but there's a huge amount to be done to
be frank this this vast amount of stuff
that can be done there Thanks yeah yes
on that question so talk about smart
education I guess that is because what
do you think that students in grad
school or under gravity or other
universities should be studying or
should be looking to do in order to be
better positioned to ah well okay so
there's a I'm going to not going to use
graphics I actually like I said I really
do have a 40-page pitch on this but one
of the first things you do is you have
to become what we call t-shape what i
mean by t-shape is for instance if you
have a tremendous depth in one technical
field you still should be able to have
an intelligent conversation with your
neighbor mind you I've worked with many
people who could not have an intelligent
conversation with their door knob the
fact of the matter is they became so
narrow that they had literally if you
had it you know a Venn diagram there's
usually some overlap no overlap the one
of its that's not smarter education you
know my own experience when I was
educated I'm a solid-state physicist I
graduated I could actually show you why
there's advanced structure and hide
morphus materials which is kind of a
bizarre and esoteric thing the fact of
the matter is if you ask me anything
about business or the things I had to
work on I had no clue so I was forced to
go get that education by literally
following a guy dogged Lee around the
world as he went into deals and learning
on the fly not a great way to not the
most efficient way to do this the fact
is you have each other and the most
powerful thing about being at a
broad-based university like CMU is you
have each other learn from each other
you know it's when you go out at night
over the beers do me a big favor
actually talk about what you do for a
living because what you'll find is the
ability to have that intelligent
conversation means that even if you
don't know the answer you will know who
to go and ask for the answer that is an
incredibly powerful statement and a
tremendous twist from being highly
siloed you know I am the world's expert
on quantum chromodynamics but I
basically given a light bulb a battery
and two pieces of wires I'd be sitting
in the dark I actually had somebody by
the way come from a
major university which will remain
nameless and shameless who actually
showed up and I gave this guy I swear to
God a battery two wires and a bell and
he sat in silence I was I was astonished
and the truth is he just never you know
so my point is the number one thing is
leverage one another you are a very
diverse group your faculty are extremely
diverse and the best of the best make
use of that that's the one first piece
that is the way you will be best
prepared because when you talk to
somebody they will not go down a rat
hole of whether you know what a
left-handed lepton is they will actually
also want to know whether you could also
have an intelligent discussion about a
smarter power grid or do you understand
the concept of using you know
computational biology to try to preclude
a disaster with a variant on h1n1 you
should be able to have a moderately
moderately you know intelligent
discussion on that board set of topics
do not narrow your that is the one that
is the number one thing they're like 100
others but right there is a incredibly
important part of the preparation is
becoming well-rounded okay that was easy
that's one you know softball how's it
thank you thank you
you